thinks he's got an answer then for when
conversations get rowdy and it's in its
opinion get offensive it's now trying
out a new feature that warns users about
to enter an online chat that it could
get quite heated although some of the
stuff flagged in the trial left some
users a bit bemused
whoa their intense conversation about
the weather bro seriously this is the
lamest one yet
twitter what's intense about this
conversation
can't believe this is happening on here
under intense conversations
dear twitter i'm a generation xr it's
gonna take more than an intense
conversation to bother me
so how does it work well a twitter
sponsor chat thread with opposing views
being thrashed out and someone wants to
join in a notice pops up helpfully
saying heads up conversations like these
can be intense it's not clear though
whether twitter is scanning for
contentious subject matter or the actual
content of a conversation colin bray
discussed it bit more with a panel of
experts
does this sound like a noble idea that's
doomed to fail because if it's moderated
by humans it's open to claims of
subjectivity if it's algorithms well we
all know how they can't really
understand the nuances of language and
discussion can it work
uh no is the very simple answer there
twitter itself has no idea how to
moderate it and winds up getting the
vast brunt of some of the most insane
arguments that bubble up on that site so
they long ago lost control of their
product this is just another laughable
way that they're yelling into the breeze
for a horse that has long ago left the
barn this is no booboo oops mistake
twitter is not fumbling the ball they're
not somehow incapable of managing their
audience it is going exactly as planned
imagine the idea when you watch
television anywhere in the world and you
get a disclaimer the following contains
lipstick children be advised do you want
to watch it yes you do
the second they put up a warning saying
whatever you do don't touch that dial
whatever you do
don't push the red button i'm going to
be the first in line along with millions
of others to push the red button this is
the perfect brand new bait hooking the
cheek off we go is there a danger that
there are certain people certain
companies certain subjects they're going
to fall foul be judged before any audio
barges even taking place absolutely
they this is already
algorithmically put to the top of the
queue it's already algorithmically fed
to everybody because there is at the
base level no difference between
intense content
and profitable content the content that
people want to engage with that stay on
the site longer and therefore give
twitter more opportunity to serve ads in
between everything else it would be
intellectually honest for us to remember
that it is a free platform like facebook
a free platform they make all the money
you get to play on their front yard they
own the lawn they can kick you off they
can put up signs they can
throw pumpkins at you it's their lawn
they own it they pay for it we just go
crazy on it so pretending like it's a
phone call where you have an implied
uh
privacy interaction
is folly the fact is we're guests there
at somebody else's dinner table and they
keep throwing hand grenades in the soup
they know that the more engagement you
get the more rancor and the more
engagement you get the more ads but also
you get more of a discourse on why there
shouldn't be rancor so
twitter is is is to me the most
incompetent of of the people doing it
because they are the most scared of
their audience but then again if i
worked at twitter i'd probably be the
most scared of my audience too when the
free speech advocates like this let's
face it they can be the noisier end of
the digital conversation can't they
because no one's getting banned no one's
getting thrown off the conversation is
still allowed to happen that's a good
thing isn't it
well
in my opinion it is what's offensive to
you is not offensive to me
and who's to say what is offensive so
that's why it's a game
again it's private property so we do
have these issues and problems think of
the beauty though if you're a politician
you can do horrible things but you can
stand up and say i'm gonna defend little
timmy who's not even born yet for
something that may offend him
and i'm gonna squelch conversation and
put up warning flags and all the
meanwhile what they physically do or
legislatively do or do in policy is
truly offensive and there's no warning
for that it just happens and then we all
get caught
you